welcome to this video playing tube or
tortilla from Finland Jim tried for
chigorin but he didn't comply hmm I
think I recently saw this line in a book
that's crazy as it sounds this is
probably okay for black just am playing
actively okay how to continue if I've
okay is this really too loose maybe if
I've really a kind of preemptive strike
before he plays c4 are you for now okay
yeah the Sun feels a bit a bit risky but
it's um it's active no no doubt about
that okay night to is 72 f 5 mm yeah I
don't want to exchange this piece
necessarily what if I take and play at
five hmm threatening a form and
goddesses the candor don't try this at
home strategy and therefore I for is a
threat
Bucheon ignores maybe rightly so hmm
okay let's try this winning a piece but
um quite obviously am it's it's it's
it's and why the white wire my king is
wide open still I have a hard time to
believe that this is enough compensation
okay let's do that also intends on IG
287 what is this is got one pawn for the
piece right yeah okay this is not enough
it's not enough i can i can even cancel
shot it's not not a big big problem we
should be seven at long castles also
also possible
yeah this is some this is my DM okay
let's not spend too much time on that
mmm should I just take probably
intending long castles I'll go here g6 I
can take Queen takes Knight c4 should be
okay okay d 6 that's knight c6
hmm
yeah it's basically just a piece and um
I will try to to get an attack myself
here up d5 but still let's play a try
there Troy
hoping to win a tempo here basically on
the Queen it takes group takes Knight f6
every seven okay this threatening
something Knight f6 maybe okay let's get
the bishop out of this done it we don't
want to fall too far behind on the clock
go here hmm maybe not just just this one
seems easier
96 SF to hang so let's try to activate
the Queen Queen g6 air Queen B 6 the
idea and they don't really think you
once the drag queens yeah this should be
enough between deform yeah or the Queen
trade I go here is got roped you wanna
so just back the bishop on c8 is always
covering g4 they've got roped it to
repeat to coming
check okay he tries to get get get to
the g4 pond it's not not resign juras i
can also at tech a 3 with g7 check g72
2g to check
okay let's uh for brief look again not
trying to not make it more complicated
than necessary check time morning so how
do how do I do this the easiest check it
wasn't really paying attention to the
clock to be honest I was wondering why
for him why he's playing on and I didn't
really pay attention to the clock but it
was always winning with this extra piece
um yeah I mean this is obviously quite
quite a risky strategy but this is not
the way to go I think this is really
just winning a piece don't I don't
really think that you can play that like
that with white very very wacky but i
think i just said it's a valid line that
so let me return to this yeah what
should you do probably develop we should
gather surf form therefore is the big
threat
as wacky as it looks or this but this is
something what so if you try to cover it
their special page 6 m it's not not
helping at all we'll go here this Bishop
e7 maybe you need to to sacrifice in a
different way I don't know but damn okay
or something else here I mean I of
course yeah this is your chance you
should try give this check this is much
better I cannot interpose then you take
FYI need to go here and then short
castle yeah this is the way to go what
the strange position Wow yeah if I take
check this looks like a big attack I
mean it it looks a bit like some some
Kings gambit position so I shouldn't
take probably and I don't need to take
immediately I have four moves like let's
say this one and very hard to tell if I
were to i would take here does think we
need five young yeah but this may be
yeah but can maybe just go here and try
to again play for this compensation yeah
this is some compensation hard to tell
if it is enough form gap would have been
very interesting the way it it happened
in the game I think it's really just a
piece for no particular compensation
alright thanks for watching